everybody comes to Rick's Shoeless Joe
queue a diversion but you may know them
better as the film's they became
Casablanca Field of Dreams Slumdog
Millionaire and fatal attraction
like the writers of those classic films
this year's nominated writers have
managed to capture the essence of their
source material in a way that is
entirely unique and original here are
this year's nominees for Best Adapted
Screenplay the Irishman
screenplay by Steven Zaillian based on
the book
I heard you paint houses by Charles
Brandon Little Women written for the
screen from Gregory based on the novel
by using the archived Joker written by
Todd Phillips and Scott silver based on
characters created by Bob Kane Bill
Finger and Jerry Robinson Joe Joe rabbit
screenplay by kogo TT
somber cadence sighs bye Christine
woman's the two popes written by Anthony
McCartan based on his play the Pope
[Applause]
Tycho ytt
this is the first Oscar and third
nomination for take over IT team
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
amazing thank you this this is really
light this one's white it's supposed to
be heavy I'd like to thank my mother
then everyone
I lost you hours ago oh yeah thank you
for being my mother and and I mean many
other reasons but forgiving me the book
that I adapted and and and this film
wouldn't have existed without you doing
that just Christine for writing the book
thank you to the producers of the film
Cathy O'Neill and Chelsea when Stanley
was a right from the beginning thank you
guys
many of you people that I want to thank
but I won't because I can't remember
them
that's it this is really great and I
dedicate this to all the indigenous kids
to live in the world do want to do art
and dance and write stories we are the
original storytellers and we can make it
here as well thank you
[Applause]